c'est dans ce quartier paisible que
c'est nous et la tragédie familiale en
début de semaine ici au chemin capoue
l'oim
une femme est décédée mercredi après
avoir été mortellement blessé au visage
avec un tournevis par l'un de ses fils
c'est un double drame au sein d'une même
famille
l'aqtis réversible d'un fils qui conduit
au décès d'une mère les voisins sont
sous le choc
ça me coupe le souffle c'est vrai ça m'a
choqué ça m'a même étonné de voir tout
ça d'un tome tout ça mon beau-frère là
m'a dit ça je croyais que j'étais pas
bien accroché déjà la tombe et à sa mère
j'ai bien sûr quand même je connais la
fille la fille idéale vers son enfant
tous les jours ils étaient tous gentils
toujours dit avec son fils
les stades la bourre je n'arrive pas à
comprendre et je ne comprenais jamais
les valeurs et lieux des joues savons
que ça qui se tient à la corde
l'homme de 21 ans souffrait d'un
handicap mental sérieux giovanni avait
déjà commis un acte violent sur un
enfant il ya un an
pourtant ses voisins décrivent un homme
calme très proche de sa mère chaque fois
je les voyais je me disais quand même
c'est pas eu besoin de leurs deux
enfants comme ça mais je tire mon
chapeau à cette dame je les voyais ans
enlevée c'est maman qui est quand même
eux résume en un mot chamakh ça m'a fait
quand même mal de les voir d'entendre le
drame voit le jeune homme a été placé en
hospitalisation sous contrainte dans un
établissement psychiatrique
pour l'heure la famille n'a pas souhaité
bénéficier de l'assistance psychologique
proposé par la commune mais des
associations comme sos crise rappelle
qu'elles sont là pour écouter et
informer les personnes qui vivent ces
drames
dans un premier temps quand on est
confronté à une situation aiguë on est
dans une phase de sidération de
difficultés à réaliser ce qui nous
arrive est donc le temps tu comprendrais
pipe intégré ce qui nous arrive c'est
aussi le temps qui va être nécessaire
pour
arrivé à demander de l'aide pour soi
même de comprendre la difficulté d'un
cadeau renaît et donc demander de l'aide
une enquête judiciaire est ouverte pour
faire la lumière sur le déroulé exact
des faits une expertise psychiatrique
plus poussée sera également menée pour
déterminer la personnalité de
l'agresseur